.
BRET?
>> Bret: ANITA, THANK YOU.
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
BEING CRITICIZED FOR OPPOSING
VOTER I.D. LAWS BECAUSE SHE SAYS
RURAL PEOPLE CANNOT GET
PHOTOCOPIES OF THEIR I.D. CARDS.
>> IN SOME PEOPLENS MINDS THAT
MEANS, WELL, YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO XEROX OR PHOTOCOPY YOUR
"TODAY" SEND IT IN TO PROVE YOU
ARE HOW ARE.
THERE ARE A WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN RURAL COMMUNITIES
THERE IS NO CINK CO-S OR OFFICE
MAX NEAR THEM.
>> Bret: LAST MONTH PRESIDENT
BIDEN SELECTED HARRIS TO LEAD
THE ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORT TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO THE BALLOT BOX.
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
EASILY WON THE STRAW POLL AT THE
CONSERVATIVE POLITICAL ACTION
CONFERENCE THIS WEEKEND IN
TEXAS.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT CAPTURING
70% OF THE BALLOTS CAST AND
FIRING UP THE CROWD THERE.
>> WITH THE HELP OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY, WE WILL DEFEAT THE
RADICAL LEFT SOCIALISTS,
MARXISTS AND THE CRITICAL RACE
THEORISTS.
WE WILL SECURE OUR BORDERS.
WE WILL STOP HEFT WING CANCEL
CULTURE.
WE WILL RESTORE FREE SPEECH AND
FAIR ELECTIONS.
AND WE WILL MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN.
>> Bret: FLORIDA REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS CAME IN
SECOND IN THAT STRAW POLL AT
21%.
LET'S BRING IN SENIOR POLITICAL
ANALYST BRIT HUME.
GOOD EVENING, BRIT.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> Brit: HEY, BRET.
>> Bret: THE FORMER PRESIDENT
WHERE HE STANDS POWER NOT JUST
CPAC BUT WITHIN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
>> BRET, I THINK HE IS GOING TO
BE WITH US A WHILE LONGER.
MAYBE A GOOD WHILE LONGER,
THINKING THAT STRAW POLL THERE
THAT'S THE MOST CONSERVATIVE
ELEMENTS OF THE PARTY.
IT ISN'T NECESSARILY THE
SENTIMENT OF THE ENTIRE PARTY
YOU THERE ARE NOT MANY
REPUBLICAN POLITICIANS WHO WANT
TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP.
NOT BECAUSE THEY THINK HE SHOULD
LEAD THEIR TICKET IN 2024 ON OR
ABOUT THAT HE -- OR THAT THEY
CAN WIN WITH HIM.
BUT BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THAT
HIS FOLLOWING IS STILL
SUFFICIENTLY STRONG IN THE PARTY
THAT THEY DARE NOT OPPOSE HIM
PUBLICLY.
THAT IS, I THINK WILL WHERE HE
STANDS.
FOR THE LAST WE'RE GOING TO DO
THIS.
WE'RE GOING TO DO.
NOT ENTIRELY CLEAR WHAT HE MEANS
THE PARTY AND HIM AT THE HEAD OF
IT OR IF HE JUST MEANS THE
PARTY, I AN AWFUL LOT OF THINGS
ARE GOING TO HAPPEN BETWEEN NOW
AND 2024 IN ANY SHAPE TO RUN RUN
OR NOT.
STILL AT THE CENTER OF THINGS
AND HE IS GOING TO MAKE NEWS AND
HAVE ATTENTION WHEREVER HE GOES.
THAT'S THE FACT OF LIFE FOR
REPUBLICANS.
>> Bret: YOU MENTIONED THAT
SPEECH.
TAKE ANOTHER PIECE OF THAT
FORMER PRESIDENT AT CPAC.
>> I WAS BANNED BY -- I WAS
BANNED BY BAD PEOPLE.
THEY ARE FAR WORSE.
I DON'T SAY I'M PERFECT.
THEY ARE FAR WORSE THAN I AM.
THEY ARE FAR WORSE.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM WAS RIGGED AGAINST THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND RIGGED
AGAINST A FAIR, DECENT AND
HONEST ELECTION.
>> Bret: I HAVE TALKED TO A LOT
OF THE REPUBLICANS WHO
ABSOLUTELY LOVE TRUMP POLICIES.
THEY LOVE THEM.
BUT THEY HAD A PROBLEM WITH
DONALD TRUMP, THE MAN.
THEY ALSO HAD, AS FAR AS WHAT HE
DID WITH TWITTER AND HOW HE
TALKED ABOUT THINGS.
BUT, ALSO, DONALD TRUMP ON
JANUARY 6TH IN THE WAKE OF THAT
AS HE TALKS MORE AND MORE ABOUT
THE STOLEN ELECTION.
HOW BIG A PROBLEM IS THAT FOR
REPUBLICANS AS A PARTY?
>> Brit: I THINK IT'S A VERY BIG
PROBLEM, BRET.
I SAW ONE POLL NOT LONG AGO THAT
REFLECTS WHAT YOU WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE IN THE
MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS SAID
THEY WOULD LIKE TO WIN WITH HIS
POLICIES A SMALLER NUMBER SAID
THEY WOULD LIKE TO WIN WITH HIM
LEADING THE WAY.
AND I THINK THAT'S BASICALLY
WHERE THE MATTER NOW STANDS.
I THINK A LOT OF RANK AND FILE
REPUBLICANS AND POLITICIANS AND
A LOT OF FILE REPUBLICAN VOTERS
WOULDN'T MIND A BIT IF HE WENT
AWAY.
THEY COULD PICK UP HIS AGENDA
AND RUN ON IT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO DATE SEEMS TO
HAVE LEFT THEM PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY.
THE PRESIDENT, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OUTLINED A LOT OF THEM
IN HIS SPEECH ON ALL KINDS OF
ISSUES, CRIME IMMIGRATION AND ON
DOWN THE LIST.
THE PARTY FEELS IT COULD BE A IN
A STRONG POSITION.
THEY'RE AFRAID TO BUCK HIM BUT
THEY'RE AFRAID THEY WILL LEAD
HIM TO A DEFEAT WHICH IS WHAT
THEY FEARED THE FIRST TIME.
AND THEN HE DID LEAD TO DEFEAT
THE SECOND TIME.
SO THAT'S, I THINK WHERE THEY'RE
IT HE SHOWS NO SIGNS OF GOING
AWAY, WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS,
YOU KNOW IF HE GETS INDICTED
THAT MIGHT CHANGE THE CALCULUS
TIME GETTING HIS BUSINESSES
TOGETHER.
>> Bret: QUICKLY YOU MENTIONED
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THEY
SEEM TO BE GIVING REPUBLICANS
LOW HANGING FRUIT WITH THE
BORDER CRISIS.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
ECONOMY AND CRIME ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS.
COPY THEY ARE NOW 70 PLUS
PERCENT OF AMERICANS WHO SAY
TOTAL I.D. FOR VOTING IS OKAY BY
THEM.
>> Brit: THIS IS A TRICKY ISSUE.
LABEL REPUBLICANS AS PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO SUPPRESS THE VOTE.
BUT A NUMBER OF THE THINGS THAT
THE REPUBLICANS WANT TO DO IN
THE LAWS THEY ARE PASSING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND SO ON ARE THINGS
THAT ARE POPULAR AND VOTER I.D.
IS VERY HIGH ON THAT LIST, BRET,
AS YOU SUGGEST.
I THINK IT'S POLITICALLY REALLY
STUPID TO COME OUT AND CRITICIZE
VOTER I.D. AND I THINK, YOU
KNOW, THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE
IN THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE KIND OF
WONDER WHETHER HAVING KAMALA
HARRIS OUT ON FRONT ON A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES HAS TURNED OUT TO
BE A VERY GOO